hello everyone this is
a research scholar from department of
bioinformatics pondicherry university
so today i am going to present
on oncogenic and non-oncogenic class
prediction for human papillomavirus
using genomic data and machine learning
approaches
so human papillomavirus is a double
standard dna virus which belongs to
papillomavidic family and it used to
cause warts and
carcinomas till that more than 220 types
of human papillomavirus has been
discovered and some of them are
asymptomatic and some of them used to
cause
carcinomas based on their genotypes they
can be little as little as they can
cause penile cancer head and neck cancer
and other energetical cancer
and some of them are asymptomatic
however
hpv and cervical cancer cervical cancer
relationship is well studied
and it is well established
as the
with advancement in technology new hpv
types are adding every year to the
database
and as the
computational power is also increasing
such as
the methods such as machine learning
models are being used in biological
senses
it is important to analyze these data to
find a relevant pattern in the data
using machine learning models so
in past few years genomic data and codon
uses information is being used
with machine learning models to annotate
the genomes
so here what we have done is
we have used rsco information to
categorize these two classes to classify
these two classes so you can see this is
known carcinogenic and this is
carcinogenic class
so here we have used six core genes from
hpv genome which are present across the
mammalian genome
so e1 and a2 which are involved in
replication and transcription and
these e6 and e7 are present in they are
oncoprotein and two of them l and l two
are capsid proteins so what we have done
is we have taken six of these protein we
have constructed an rsu table best
relative codon synonymous codon usage
table which will tell you the codon
biases so based on the rsc value more
than 1.6 we have constructed a table and
from there we have summed up based on
the wobble nucleotide at the third
position so uh if
a
on third position if a
adenine is there so all that and
all the codons which are having adenine
we have summed up the rsc value so this
is how we are constructed for four
bubble nucleotides for each gene so we
got 24 features
uh in a feature table for six of the
genes and we have fed this two machine
learning model which was able to
classify the carcinogenic and
non-carcinogenic class of the
hpv for this we have uh
used uh linear and
non-linear model combination such as
linear regression
and linear discriminant analysis
knnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnlnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnnn
abs and svm
so we have find out based on training
and testing data we have found out svm
and logistic regression performed well
and we have a hypertune the svm model
and we find out that linear kernel with
scale gamma performed based on our test
data set
and logistic regression also performed
almost same as you can see
at the end uh we found out with svm the
model accuracy on five rows five fold
cross validation it was 98 percent 98.4
percent on trending data set and 98
percent on test data set the mcc value
on test data set was 90.91 which is 91
the specificity and sensitivity which
are the
important measures in machine learning
model
accuracy
evaluation so we are having specificity
100 percent and sensitivity 98 percent
and balanced accuracy on our imbalance
test data set was 99
and as you can see
in our
in our confusion matrix we are having
six of the carcinogenic sample
classified correctly out of 57 56
non-carcinogenic classified correctly
only one non-carcinogenic is classified
as carcinoma
so in our initial
data set we were having 18 carcinogenic
and 129 non-carcinogenic
at the end we created
a balanced data set by oversampling the
minor class which is carcinogenic so 129
129 a balanced data set we have created
and we tested on our test data set
so what we concluded out of that is
linear models such as svm
with linear kernel can be used such as
logistic regression linear models can be
also used for hpv class prediction
and
genomic composition information such as
codon usage information can be
integrated into these models to classify
newly discovered hpv phenotype and these
models can be helpful for the clinician
in early diagnosis of novel hpv
so we have got the roc well do
on test data set is almost 100
so this
so we would like to
thank uh
dvd
for providing a
financial assistance in the form of
liberty build philosophy
thank you everyone
you